[музика]
північ Чернігівщини неподалік
українського білоруського кордону
один з механізованих підрозділів
відточує бойові навички аби бути
готовими до всього бойові стрільби
відпрацювали парами стрільби з заміною в
магазині
це про новий можливий наступ з Білорусі
з'являються у
Сирії ж тут неподалік білоруського
кордону про загрозу з півночі не
забувають Ось такі навчання зі стрільби
тактики і медицини тут проводяться
регулярно і за будь-якої погоди
поки ці бійці боронять північний кордон
але будь-якої миті за потреби їх можуть
відправити на інші ділянки фронту завжди
Є над чим працювати завжди навіть якщо
ти там досвідчений мегабоєць вчитися
працювати завжди є
тому сьогодні
хлопці молодці відпрацювали з заходами
безпеки саме головне
закріпили на практиці свої навички та
знання то би ж бойова готовність
особового складу найвищому рівні
кордон на замку Як ви там себе не повів
противник
він нас не пройде
серед військових чимало молоді 21-річний
Ярослав пішов служити чотири місяці тому
навчання як проходив
а тут я не стрельбах в дане місце
хлопець певен що ворог не наважиться
знову перетнути північний кордон України
не боїмося
поруч тренуються і більш досвідчені
військові Андрій на фронті з 2017 року а
з початку повномасштабного вторгнення
був одним з оборонців Чернігова зараз
більш Ми спокійно Там деякі участки
обстрілюють
росіяни а так але
не можна розслаблятися порох потрібно
держати сухим
і зброю набагатові
серйозно військові ставляться й до
занять із тактичної медицини
говорила проська школа вчителька то есть
шов турнікет йому не треба Олександр
який вдає пораненого знає що такі
навички можуть врятувати життя Я їздив в
зону бойових дій
Житомирська область і там
відпрацьовували ці дії коли копали копи
прилітало і ми забирали ранених забрали
вбитих на жаль Я особисто забирав
ранених
для цього віку Це дуже важко
активно тре військовій по інший бік
кордону Як повідомляє український
генштаб Білорусь привела окремі
з'єднання та частини у вищий ступінь
бойової готовності правозахисники кажуть
що в країні триває прихована мобілізація
призвати пропонують навіть студентів усе
це на тлі обіцянок Володимира Путіна вже
влітку розмістити в Білорусі тактичну
ядерну зброю
надо будь як ми з Путіним Ми з Путіним
вирішимо і введемо сюди Якщо треба буде
і стратегічне озброєння і вони це мають
розуміти поганці там за кордоном які
сьогодні намагаються підірвати нас
зсередини і ззовні ми Ні перед чим не
зупинимося захищаючи свої країни свої
держави і свої народи протягом останніх
місяців Олександр Лукашенко регулярно
зустрівся з російсь
кою Він вимагає від Москви нових
гарантій безпеки аби Росія захищала
територію Білорусі як свою експерти
застерігають можливе посилення
російської військової присутності у цій
так званій союзній державі водночас
військові РФ І так постійно перебувають
у Білорусі за даними української
прикордонної служби їх там близько
чотирьох тисяч та про формування
ударного угруповання поки не йдеться
Прикордоння Чернігівщини яке межує з
білоруссю живе більш-менш спокійно з
Білорусі не ведуться обстріли а від
жовтня звідти в Україну налетять навіть
ракети і шахеди натомість з території
Росії Яка теж межує з чернігівщиною по
прикордонним селам постійно працюють
міномети і ствольна артилерія звуки
вибухів чути навіть у містечку Городня
що запонад 20 км до кордону слышим
як жили раніше це місто одними з перших
зустріло колони російської техніки які
рухалися на Чернігів 24 лютого 2022 року
нині через понад рік після звільнення
залишки цієї техніки нагадують
городнянця про війну начала как бы по
началу после того как вот выгнали их
когда вот начали постепенно люди
приезжать
как-то такое был депрессию всех были
как-то переживали что вот вот вдруг
опять вот а постепенно становится всё
как бы на свои места как бы всё как бы
мы знаем о то что нас защищает мы
вообще-то вірим наши силы чи то ще раз
повторюся у нас муж зять братусія
військовослужбовців то сюди вони не
пойдуть ну тут іще вопрос то що я молода
Ну ось я смотрю если пусти они дожджмент
водночас у те що Білорусь повноцінно
ступить у війну проти України городнянці
не хочуть вірити получається вони
коридор для наступу на Україну
як би
таке 50 на 50 відношення до них
Я думаю ета
п приїжджали в Україну
к нам в городню везде Я думаю они это
белоруси самі этого не допустят
військові ж звикли готуватись до гіршого
біля кордону зведені кілька ешелонів
оборони кілометри ось таких міцно
обладнаних траншей і окопів саме такі
позиції траншеї двійнички створені для
того щоб підрозділ міг вести оборону
ввести вогонь
не пускати противника пройти далі до
наших днів на всіх можливих проходах де
противник може пройти
всюди зроблені міні поля так само на
мостах мости також підготовлені до
підриву всі
Тобто ми тут повністю підготовлені
впевнені що противник судові не пройде
військові постійно стежать за тим що
відбувається по той бік кордону а у
вільний час займаються військовою
творчістю поки на кордоні тихо готують
Ось такі Великодні крашанки На мою думку
що навряд чи вони вже підуть сюди тому
що дуже багато тут їх чекає сюрпризів
по-перше по-друге провокації можливість
На мою думку Максимум і все Тому що вони
теж зрозуміли що ми проводимо
аеророзвідку так само і вони проводяться
розвитку вони розуміють що їх тут чекає
після війни